[Musik]
vorbei
sie ist talentiert fleißig ehrgeizig und
sie hat sich in den kopf gesetzt in
hollywood karriere zu machen
in einer welt in der nicht nur das blut
eine illusion ist kämpft sich sabrina
kern konsequent hoch wie will es die
sängerin und schauspielerin auf den
roten teppich an der branche schaffen in
der andere einfach so über leichen gehen
davon handelt dieser film
ja
die junge frau aus der schweiz
ich finde eigentlich ist das die idee
entstanden dass ich mit auge und in
wirklichkeit ist in ordnung
wir kriegen immer volle bezirk sie sich
gemerkt dann irgendwann dass es gar
nicht
auf dem filmset dreht sich alles um die
schweizerin
sie ist der star ihre erste hauptrolle
der friller heißt santa casa und hat ein
budget von rund eineinhalb millionen
dollar
das ist der anbau der regisseur drehte
drei folgen des horror film klassiker so
die dutzende von millionen einspielte
[Musik]
der amerikaner hat einen hervorragenden
ruf in der branche
für die 28 jährige schweizerin ist die
hauptrolle in seinem neuesten film ein
riesiger karrieresprung
während der vierwöchigen dreharbeiten
wunder star des films in einem
heruntergekommenen haus in der nähe des
filmsets das ist die andere seite der
glitzerwelt
jetzt fehlt mir immer vor 11 bis 11 im
schaumburger job gut
das heißt sie zum kaffee holen
sabrina kerns gage beträgt weniger als
10.000 franken und kosten zu sparen
teilte sich das haus mit kollegin
courteney helgerson die im film eine
nebenrolle spielt auf dieser tafel hat
die schauspielerin ihre emotionen für
jede szene des films erarbeitet so
bereitet sie sich auf den dreh tag vor
schauspiel kollegin courteney helgerson
hatte sich ebenfalls für die hauptrolle
geworden
sie unterlag aber ihre kollegin aus der
schweiz die viel weniger hollywood
erfahrung hatten sie sabrina nicht sie
hat ihnen die hauptrolle weggeschnappt
nein sabrina sticht wirklich heraus alle
anderen schauspielerinnen und
schauspieler treten dahinter zurück
aber wir haben alle unseren auftritten
können uns genug präsentieren
auf jeden fall werde ich nicht versuchen
dich hinterrücks aus dem weg zu räumen
gefilmt wird in einer original kulisse
im fernen atlanta
ok
sabrina kerns glaubwürdigkeit und
authentizität begeisternden regisseurs
nicht über das wohl und die zürcherin
spielt eine schwangere frau die in einem
kloster gefangen gehalten wird
sabrina kern absolvierte die renommierte
american academy of dramatic arts in los
angeles
viele hollywood-stars haben dort ihr
handwerk gelernt
2016 hatte sich die schweizer in die
hauptrolle in einem theaterprojekt von
regisseur darren baus magath hat ihre
erste zusammenarbeit wurde von den
kritikern gelobt
ich habe sabrina für mein theater
projekt in äußerst schwierige
situationen gesteckt sie musste ohne
jede vorbereitung mit dem publikum
interagieren und den raum ausfüllt
dann habe ich die anforderungen an sie
immer weiter hochgeschraubt und sabrina
ging wie ein profi damit ich realisierte
wenn sie auf der bühne solche
herausforderungen meistert kann sie das
auch vor der kamera
wir haben sieben monate gemeinsam am
theater projekt gearbeitet
für mich war schnell klar dass ich mit
ihr einen film machen will
es ist aufregend jemanden zu entdecken
mit diesem film will sabrina einem
breiteren publikum präsentieren
ja
[Musik]
sabrina kern lebt seit einem jahr mit
ihrer zweiten familie wie sie es nennt
in los angeles
alle vier wohnen gemeinsam in einer wg
[Musik]
das sind ihr freund stehe und dessen
schwester go bekannt als indie pop duos
ehemann eve ist profigolfer vier
schweizer die sich an diesem
samstagmorgen einige stunden freizeit
gönnen bevor sie wieder um einen guten
platz im scheinwerferlicht der
traumfabrik kämpfen werden
[Musik]
alle vier arbeiten hart an ihren
karrieren
momentan ist los angeles der mittelpunkt
ihres universums
doch das kann sich schnell ändern aber
das ist eben wir versuchen werden
künstler rund um möglichst günstig zu
wohnen teilen sich die freunde ein
kleines haus viel privatsphäre bleibt da
nicht zumal das haus auch noch
übungsraum und tonstudio ist
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nach unzähligen würden hat sich sabrina
kern eines der heißbegehrten künstler
visa für schauspieler
[Musik]
der nachteil dieses visums die
schweizerin darf ausschließlich in der
showbranche arbeiten und gerade da ist
der stellenmarkt besonders umkämpft hier
fand sie ihren ersten job
sie ist ihm bis heute treu geblieben
einmal pro woche arbeitet sie für eine
firma die dinger in einer original
flugzeugkabine der airline panam
anbietet
sie ist als schauspielerin angestellt
und gibt die metro der kabine
erfunden hat das spektakel ihr chef
anthony thet denn eigentlich
spitzenmanager bei united airlines ist
sabrina ist unglaublich lustig wenn sie
mal verheiratet ist fehlt einfach etwas
die durchsagen diese macht ihre rollen
und sie als person sind so witzig dass
sie das flugzeug erst richtig zum leben
erweckt
500 franken und mehr bezahlen die gäste
für einen abend in einem stilechten ein
trio aus den 70er jahren
ihr chef erkannte schnell dass die
tochter eines wird der pass noch ganz
andere qualitäten hat deshalb
koordiniert die schauspieler die
nebenbei auch noch den ganzen ablauf
hinter den kulissen die eigene
investition sein herz hing in der ich
mir für diese hektische schicht verdient
sie gerade einmal 150 franken
und sie ist zufrieden auch das ist eine
realität in hollywood
[Applaus]
experience designer taschen schon der
höhepunkt des abends die schweizerin
moderiert dort gretchen mit einem
extremen deutschen akzent eine
modenschau mit historischen panam
uniformen
sabrina kern besucht ihre familie in
zürich
mutter und vater nicola betreiben
mehrere restaurants eines der lokale
führt sabrinas schwester melanie
wir sind sehr an die familien vor allem
was können aber sehr viel und was
speziell ist zwar nicht gehört erstmals
technology mit gegründet
aber es gehört aber ja bevor sie sich
ins hollywood abenteuer stürzte
studierte sabrina kern an der
universität zürich kommunikation politik
und bwl mit viel drive und der fabrik
haben und ich hab vorher muss das
besucher- und sie versucht selbst und
sieht zu guttenberg und die freude da
ist man sich oft um die eltern aber los
kaufen könnte
noch ist ja auch finanziell immer wieder
auf die unterstützung ihrer eltern
angewiesen
überhaupt probieren sie nur dann wenn
ich das gleich zu haben
dann wäre ich einfach noch schwieriger
unter druck machen ist aber es hilft
sich
obwohl sie das nicht will ich habe ich
mein echtes aber ich nur zweimal die
woche ganz unabhängig sie und er wollte
raus aber die karibische hitze nicht
selber zahlen
aber klar ist die große unterstützung
steven ich war gerne bescheiden wir
haben die mega leistung zurück in los
angeles im gemeinsamen horrorfilm
spielte sie die faschistische oberin
heute will caroline hannah sie ihre
schweizer kollegen für die luftakrobatik
begeistern
die sache hat aber einen haken doch
sabrina kern weiß mit angst und
zurückhaltung schafft sie es nie in
hollywood carolyn hennessy blickt auf
eine lange karriere zurück und ist in
hollywood bestens vernetzt
davon kann yukon sabrina kern nur
profitieren wie man karriere macht ihn
hollywood du musst ein guter teamplayer
sein
deine aufgabe ist es allen anderen das
leben leichter zu machen und du musst
lernen das wörtchen nein zu leben
dieses wort muss dein bester freund sein
du wirst es oft hören ich habe ihn auf
dem richtigen weg keine frage vergessen
sie nicht ich stand mit ihr vor der
kamera und auf der bühne
ich hoffe nur sie erinnert sich an uns
kleine menschen wenn sie ein großer star
ist übrigens sie hat gerade einen emmy
gewonnen
gegen die höhenangst hilft auch die
lobeshymne der etablierten kollegen
nicht am trapez gilt das gleiche wie in
der filmbranche aufstieg und fall liegen
gefährlich nahe beisammen
immerhin hier gibt es ein auffangnetz
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
caroline hennessy trainiert seit 16
jahren am trapez für sabrina care ist
dies die premiere
erste lektion nur wenn man sich nach
jedem absturz wieder aufrappelt gelingt
irgendwann der berauschende höhenflug
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
fans
[Musik]
um sich auch als sängerin im
showbusiness zu empfehlen produziert
sabrina kern ihr erstes musikvideo das
lied hat sie mit freund stehe und einem
schauspielkollegen geschrieben
die regie macht deren baus mann der
regisseur des horrorfilms heute ist die
28-jährige seine chefin
[Musik]
sabrina kerns budget für das musikvideo
beträgt gerade einmal 2000 franken
deshalb hat sie freunde und bekannte aus
der branche zusammen getrommelt die
bereit sind auf ihre gage zu verzichten
auch das ist hollywood ganz viele
menschen werden sich kurz vor dem
durchbruch
für diesen traum opfern sie fast alles
das scheitern ist in der traumfabrik ein
tabuthema aber vielleicht ist gerade ein
gesunder selbstzweifel mehr wert als
blinder optimismus es macht spaß es
macht spaß so schön wie mich ist auch
schon wieder aber es ist schön aber das
machen wir sind mit der apa dass man
nicht von einer frau als sie das
überhaupt
ich habe immer ich glaube dass ich es
schaffe das
[Musik]
andrin
hallo
[Musik]